bonjour à tous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
députés de la Doma d'État
citoyen de Russie dans cette adresse
je vous parle à une époque qui est
importante complexe et
très déterminante pour notre pays et
dans le monde entier ce sera un
événement des événements historiques qui
vont définir l'avenir de notre pays de
notre peuple et chacun de nous
à une responsabilité colossale
il y a un nom pour rassurer la sécurité
de notre pays et pour assurer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur certains
territoires de l'Ukraine et qui après ou
il y a eu cette
occupation de
ces régions et nous allons
systématiquement accomplir tous les
actes qui nous impose nous incombent
depuis 2014 le don de bain savent lutter
pour son droit à vivre sur son
territoire et parler sa propre langue et
n'a jamais
céder devant le blocus devant la haine
du
régime de Kiev et ils espérait et ils
attendaient l'aide de la Russie et ils
avaient foi
en notre arrivée cependant et vous le
savez très bien nous faisions tout
tout ce qui était possible pour résoudre
ce problème d'une manière pacifique et
d'une manière patiente nous avons
mené des négociations pour sortir de ce
conflit extrêmement dur mais derrière
notre dos il se tramait un scénario tout
à fait différent les gouvernants
européens de d'Occident
en fait agissait pour
gagner du temps pour donner la
possibilité aux régimes de Kiev de
se livrer à ces assassinat politique
c'est humiliations et ses actions
théoristes sur le donne pas dans les
écoles militaires de l'Occident
vont se préparer à fournir des armes et
à fond le commencement de cette
opération militaire spéciale il y a fait
des
négociations entre Kiev et les pays
occidentaux pour la fourniture de
système entier aériennes de d'armes
lourdes et toutes ces tentatives du
régime
ukrainien
aller aussi jusqu'à demander une aide
par des armes nucléaires et les
[Musique]
Occidentaux organisaient des
laboratoires secrets de d'armes
biologiques et
se préparer et préparer le régime de
Kiev a une grande guerre la grande
guerre qu'il préparait et maintenant il
l'a vu publiquement sans
n'avoir la moindre honte et le format de
Normandie et tout cela s'était un bluff
c'était un spectacle politique et
pendant que le sang coulé dans le don de
bain c'est la Russie très sincèrement
cherché une solution pacifique il jouait
sur la vie et la mort des hommes et il
jouait avec des cartes faussées et cette
méthode
de
d'action fallacieuse ils ont détruit la
Yougoslavie l'Irak la Libye la Syrie et
cette une honte dont il n'arriveront pas
à se libérer la notion d'honneur de
pureté de droiture cela ne concerne
aucun de ces pays en fait ils ont
l'habitude de dédicateurs qui ont
l'hégémonie et qui peuvent mépriser le
monde entier et ils ont aussi le même
mépris pour les peuples de leurs propres
pays ils ont aussi
tromper leur propre peuple en
prétendants chercher des solutions
pacifiques y compris au Conseil de
sécurité pour le don de base et en fait
c'était un système de mensonges
systématique et totale en fait nous
défendons les intérêts qui ne sont pas
seulement les nôtres mais aussi pour
cesser cette
distinction que l'on fait entre les pays
prétenduesment civilisés dans le monde
et les autres leur permettant d'être
d'autant plus
agressif nous sommes nous étions prêts à
un dialogue ouvert avec l'Occident nous
disions que nous avons besoin d'une
ciste d'un système de sécurité
unique et indiv les nous cherchions à
travailler ensemble avec eux et la
réponse était soit confuse soit tout à
fait hypocrite ça c'était dans les
paroles mais il y a eu des actions aussi
c'était l'élargissement de l'OTAN vers
nous frontières c'était de nouveau
dispositifs de
défense antimissile il cherchait à
établir un parapluie contre nous et
c'était pour se rapprocher de la Russie
en fait il n'y a aucun pays dans le
monde qui est autant de base à
l'extérieur son territoire que les
États-Unis d'Amérique ils ont des
centaines de bases militaires dans le
monde toute la planète en est constellé
et on l'a vu la manière dont ils sont
renoncés à des accords internationaux
comme ces accords sur les de moyenne
portée et ces systèmes qui assuraient la
paix dans le monde pourquoi le
faisait-il mais ils ne font rien sans
avoir un objectif et en décembre 2021
nous avions envoyé à l'OTAN et à aux
États-Unis des projets d'accord sur la
garantie de sécurité en
influant des positions fondamentales
pour nous et nous avons reçu une réponse
directe c'était un
un nom catégorique cela signifie que ils
avaient donné déjà le raccord pour
l'agression et la menace
continuait de grandir et en février
2022 tout était prêt pour lancer une
nouvelle action punitive sur le don de
base et dès 2014
qui est annoncé l'artillerie des dons et
des avions contre le donne parce que
nous avons regarder le souvenir de cela
de ces frappes sur Donetsk mais pas
seulement sur tunnel mais aussi dans
d'autres villes en 2015 ils sont tentés
une nouvelle attaque directe sur le don
de bain et ils sont continués le blocus
et des frappes sur les populations
civiles et cela a l'encontre de toutes
les
résolutions du Conseil de sécurité et
cela a été fait d'une manière tout à
fait catégorie c'est eux qui ont lancé
cette guerre et nous nous avons utilisé
la force et nous n'utilisons la force
que pour arrêter cette guerre
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle attaque sur donuts sur le
dolbask sur Logan
il comprenait que
la suite c'était une attaque sur la
Crimée et sébastopold nous en étions
conscient et nous savons ces objectifs
qui sont dit tout à fait tout vertement
par Kief nous le savons très bien nous
défendons la vie des hommes nous
défendons la vie de nos hommes et
l'Occident a dépensé déjà plus de 150
milliards de dollars pour le soutien à
l'Ukraine et à Kiev et en 202 2021 il
n'y a que 60 milliards de dollars qui
ont été versés pour apporter un soutien
au pays les plus démunis donc on
comprend bien 150 mill iards contre 60
et il s'agissait que ces pays qui
recevaient cette
aide il devait
se soumettre entièrement aux volonté et
ces flux d'argent pour la guerre ne
s'arrête pas et on cherche un fomenter
des troubles dents différents pays du
monde lors d'une conférence récente à
munique il y a eu des attaques contre la
Russie on avait l'impression que cette
confiance n'avait été réunie que pour
faire oublier tout ce que le prétendu
Occident a lancé au cours des dernières
années des régions entières ont été
lancées dans le chaos les experts
américains eux-mêmes disent que la suite
des guerres et ça n'est pas nous qui
avons inventé ces chiffres c'est les
Américains qui fournissent qui les
fournissent à la suite des guerres qui
ont été lancées après 2001 par les
Américains plus de 2 900 000 hommes sont
Mortus de 38 millions de personnes ont
été réduits à l'état de réfugiés et cela
il fallait l'effacer de la mémoire de
l'humanité il fallait faire entendre que
il ne s'est rien passé or personne
n'oublie cela personne ne l'oubliera et
donc c'est tragédies et c'est
moi
on le l'oublie parce que il y a des
trillions de dollars qui sont en jeu
pour mettre en place des systèmes
prétendument démocratiques mais qui sont
en fait des systèmes s'autoritaires il
faut
créer cette image de l'ennemi et
faire oublier les
scandales de corruption qui sont
constamment présentes et qui découle des
problèmes
internes économiques et
en fait
au début du 20e siècle
les projets des pays occidentaux ont
ouvert la voie aux nazis
et maintenant c'est un projet aussi qui
se reproduit en foi à ce projet qui
revient cette destruction de la
Russie en lui arrachant
l'Ukraine c'est une un rêve qui avait
été celui de l'Autriche Hongrie de
l'Empire
allemand et en soutenant le putsch de
2014 qui a été
anticonstitutionnel qui était contre
l'État c'était comme si rien ne s'était
produit
qui constitue la pince idéologique de
tout cela ce sont les brigandes
spéciales de des forces
ukrainiennes et on a honte de
d'apprendre que ces
unité spéciale Ukraine ce sont
intitulées et d'élever ce du nom de ces
unités allemandes qui ont
occupé
et l'on voit les symboles
SS qui sont repris par les ukrainiens et
qui ont et ce sont sur les chars
Ukrainiens ou des en signes des insignes
des emblèmes néo-nazis et on voit bien
qui de qui il se réclame et on peut
s'étonner qu'en Occident personne ne
remarque là pourquoi mais en fait ils
sont foutent excusez-moi du terme il
s'en fiche parce que il ceux qui
comptent c'est la lutte contre la Russie
ce qui est important c'est que le
combat se fasse contre la Russie et donc
on peut utiliser tout ce qui vous tombe
sous la main c'est les terroristes c'est
n'importe qui pourvu qu'il porte les
armes contre la Russie le projet de
l'anti Russie fait partie du
de cette ce projet de revanche contre là
aussi création de
foyer de conflit aux frontières de notre
pays et ce sont les mêmes objectifs qui
sont poursuivis depuis le 20e siècle
c'est
orienté l'action contre la Russie contre
l'EST nous ne faisons pas la guerre au
peuple ukrainien
savons que ce peuple a été
l'otage du régime de Kiev et de ses
patrons occidentaux qui ont fait
occupé politiquement militairement et
économiquement ce pays ils ont détruit
l'industrie ukrainienne ils sont piqués
les ressources naturelles et ils ont
assuré une dégradation sociale et une
augmentation des inégalités et là il
n'est pas difficile de d'avoir de la
matière première pour lancer des actions
militaires et c'est Jean a été préparés
à devenir de la chair à canon c'est
triste à dire mais c'est un fait la
responsabilité de ce conflit
ukrainien de cet escalade cette
responsabilité c'est celle des élites
occidentales et du régime de Kiev qui
est étranger au peuple en fait ce régime
ne sert pas les intérêts de son peuple
mais des pays de tiers de bêtisiers qui
utilisent l'Ukraine comme un boutoir
comme un bélier contre la Russie je ne
vais pas vous parler des
intentions qu'ils ont de lancer de
nouvelles offensives mais il y a une
chose qui peut être certaine pour tous
plus les armes à longue portée
occidentale
seront livrés à l'Ukraine plus loin il
faut que nous repulsions cette menace de
nos frontières il est tout simplement
ne dissimule pas leurs objectifs ils
veulent
obtenir une défaite stratégique de la
Russie qu'est-ce que cela signifie cela
signifie mettre un terme à la Russie une
fois pour toutes
que ce conflit local
soit mise en France avec cette
affrontement mondiale c'est la manière
dont nous comprenons les choses et nous
allons réagir de cela
de la manière qui convient parce qu'il
s'agit là de l'existence même de notre
pays ils ne peuvent pas ne pas se rendre
compte du fait que il est impossible de
vaincre la Russie
sur le terrain militaire voilà pourquoi
il multiplie les attaques dans le champ
des médias dans le champ de
l'information il s'attaque aux jeunes et
là encore une fois et constamment il
pervertissent les faits historiques et
continue leurs attaques sur une autre
histoire sur la l'Église orthodoxe russe
qu'est-ce qu'ils font avec leur propre
peuple la destruction de la famille de
la
l'identité culturelle et nationale la
pédophilie devient la norme dans leur
vie et les prêtres sont
contraints de donner leur bénédiction à
des mariages homosexuels les
adultes ont le droit de vivre comme il
l'entendait nous avons bien sûr
reconnaissance de ce fait personne ne
cherche à s'immiscer dans la vie privée
était
êtres mais il faut leur dire mais
regardez les écritures cintres garder
les principes de toutes les religions du
monde tout est dit y compris le fait que
la famille c'est l'alliance entre un
homme et une femme
[Applaudissements]
ces textes sacrés sont l'objet de mise
en doute
l'église américaine nous dit donc à
l'intention de créer l'image d'un Dieu
au jour indéterminé
ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils font des
millions de gens en Occident sont
conscients du fait qu'on les mènent vers
une catastrophe spirituelle véritable et
les élites
sont en train de
sombrer dans la démence
il ne se soigne pas il c'est l'heure à
faire mais nous devons défendre nos
enfants contre cette dégradation et dont
contre cette dégénérescence
il est évident que l'Occident va essayer
de
d'ébranler notre société de
ils vont faire fond sur des traîtres qui
ont se mépris de leur propre
patrie et qui seront prêts à se mettre
au service de ceux qui sont prêts à les
payer et ceux qui ont choisi la trahison
et qui ont choisi de
lutter contre la sécurité l'intégrité de
notre pays nous ne ferons jamais comme
le régime de Kiev et les élites
occidentales qui font cette chasse aux
sorcières nous n'allons pas chercher à
anéantir ceux qui ont fait un pas de
côté c'est un leurre à eux de le faire
avec leur propre conscience c'est eux
qui auront ont cela ce poids sur leur
conscience mais il faut que le peuple de
Russie les citoyens
soient capables
de d'être
[Applaudissements]
à son juste prix se comportement et
notre peuple
pluriethnique multinationales
reste unis et comprend nos objectifs et
nos actions
et ce soutien nous le sentons dans un
véritable patriotisme qui se fait jour
c'était sentiment qui est historiquement
inhérent au peuple russe et qui nous
frappent par ça
dignité on voit cette volonté de faire
de son propre destin un destin unique
avec le destin de son peuple chers amis
je voudrais vous remercier tous
remercier tout le peuple russe de son
courage et de sa résolution remercier
nos héros de
l'armée du de la marine
de la garde russe des
volontaires de ceux qui
participent au groupe bars je dois
présenter mes excuses aussi de ne pas
pouvoir les nommer tous quand je
préparais cette
adresse j'ai
préparé une très très longue liste de
toutes ces unités combattantes mais je
le répète il est impossible de les
nommer tous ces jeux craignais de
pour certains à ceux que je me nommerai
pas je voudrais remercier les familles
les épouses les mers je leur présente
mes hommage je présente mes hommages
aussi au médecin aux assistants aux
infirmiers ou
somme aux cheminots
[Musique]
ingénieur civile qui
reconstitue les infrastructures à ceux
qui travaillent dans l'industrie de
l'armement et qui travaille 24 heures
sur 24 et à tous ceux aussi qui dans la
culture assure
la santé et la sécurité je remercie les
maîtres les enseignants qui ont le souci
des jeunes générations ceux qui
travaillent dans des conditions très
dures à proximité du front les acteurs
de la culture et qui viennent travailler
présenter aussi des spectacles dans les
hôpitaux les journalistes les
correspondants de guerre qui raconte la
vérité au monde entier et aussi
les prêtres est responsable des
religion qui sont présents aussi auprès
des combattants les entrepreneurs tous
ceux qui assurent leur devoir
professionnelle
civique et humains je voudrais en
particulier
aux habitants de la région de Gonesse de
luganz et de Carson vous avez vous-même
par référendum prononcé vous vous êtes
prononcé sur votre avenir dans des
conditions ou vous étiez à proximité des
combats or rien n'est plus fort que
votre résolution d'être
avec votre pays la Russie
nous avons commencé et nous allons
continuer
[Applaudissements]
aux habitants de Gonesse louginsk à des
apparentiers de Kerson est un hommage je
n'y joint et nous allons amplifier notre
campagne de développement de ces
nouveaux sujets de la Fédération il faut
régénérer les entreprises et les emplois
les pores de la mer d'Azov qui sont de
nouveau des ports de mer intérieure de
Russie faudra construire de nouvelles
routes comment Crimée qui a maintenant
une liaison
fiable par voie de terre avec toutes les
régions de réussie nous allons continuer
la réalisation de ces plans ces régions
assurent leur soutien à
personne et saporogier nous sommes
maintenant douloureux ensemble et donc
nous sommes devenus encore plus fort et
ils nous ferons tout pour que cette
terre qui est la nôtre
redevienne une terre de paix pour que la
sécurité des hommes soit assurée et pour
cela
[Applaudissements]
et pour les générations savent venir
pour la restauration de la justice
historique pour cela un nos héros et nos
soldats sont en train de combattre je
voudrais vous demander de
rendre hommage à ceux qui ont donné leur
vie à la population civile qui est morte
sous les frappes
je vous remercie
pour les épouses des enfants de ceux qui
sont morts pour leur Patrick de même que
c'est Jean de la jeune gare de krasnodon
qui pendant la grande guerre patriotique
ont lutté pour le don-binze contre les
nazis et ils ont
manifester leur esprit de sacrifice et
cette haute spiritualité et il faut
aider ceux qui ont perdu leurs proches
à élever une nouvelle génération
les familles de chacun des participants
à l'opération militaire spéciale doivent
être entourés de
soins et de
sollicitude et d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
un fond d'État qui sera destiné à porter
une aide personnelle à chacun des
membres des familles des victimes de ce
conflit de l'opération militaire
spéciale ce sera une aide médicale
psychologique
l'organisation de vacances le
développement de d'activités sportives
d'activité d'entreprise de formation de
formation professionnelle et ce fond va
devoir aussi assuré une aide à domicile
en particulier des systèmes pour la
fourniture de prothèse et de
facilitation de la vie il faut que
les dirigeants des régions
prennent sur eux de tout ce travail
d'organisation
se font d'État va devoir fonctionner
d'une manière la plus simple possible
avec un guichet unique et sur pour
chacune des familles de
un ancien combattant il faut que chaque
famille que chaque personne soit suivie
de manière personnelle il faut que en
temps réel leur problème soit résolus
dès cette né les structures de ce fond
est à vont être déployés dans toutes les
régions de la Fédération de Russie
l'aide pour les anciens combattants de
la Grande Guerre et ce fond va pouvoir
également prendre à sa charge ses
actions et je vais demander aux membres
du gouvernement de s'occuper de cela la
création de ce fond ne diminuant rien
les responsabilités des autres
entités et autorité les régions
municipalités vont devoir
s'intéresser aux
anciens combattants ou
militaires il faut que les maires des
villes et les chefs de région puissent
se rendre aussi sur la ligne de front
pour apporter leur soutien moral à leur
compatriotes maintenant ce sont
les gens
et
les questions de Davida
d'assurance de leur besoin
je comprends d'après les nombreuses
appels qui me parviennent que ces
demandes ne sont pas satisfaites et
tout le monde le comprend l'opération
militaire spéciale entraîne des
charges extrêmement lourdes pour chacun
il faut que les mobilisés tous les
militaires tous les participants à
l'opération militaire spéciale de même
les volontaires puissent avoir une
période de
repos de 14 jours minimum par tous les
six mois de façon à ce que chaque
militaire puisse revenir dans ces foyers
pendant quelques jours chers collègues
nous avons
un plan de
reconstitution et d'évolution des forces
armées
2021-2025 c'est un plan qui est
actuellement en cours de révision et
pour renforcer
l'armée et la marine pour développer les
forces armées il faut
se baser sur
l'expérience militaire réelle acquise au
cours de l'opération militaire spéciale
c'est une expérience qui est extrêmement
importante pour ce qui est de
l'équipement de nos forces nucléaires
nous avons un état de préparation de 91%
et il faut que nous arrivions à une un
niveau de préparation
aussi important dans toutes les
composantes de nos forces militaires
des officiers sous-officiers qui ont
montré leur capacité à commander ils
sont très très nombreux ils seront
en
priorité
promu et
envoyer pour subir une formation
complémentaire ils seront aussi
nécessaire dans le domaine civil dans
tous les organes de décision c'est très
important il faut que ces hommes
puissent comprendre que leur pays
et
capable d'estimer ce leur expérience à
sa juste valeur il faut améliorer la
qualité de nos forces armées et nous
avons des moyens techniques
de très bonne qualité
ils sont bien supérieurs pour certains
leur s’équivalent étranger il faut
développer la production en masse de ces
moyens de César et cela il faut que nous
le fassions sur la base de nos
connaissances de nos moyens
scientifiques et techniques et il y aura
un développement de
commandes militaire les bureaux d'études
de nos industries d'armement font appel
à des jeunes
talentueux qui sont fidèles
aux traditions de
nos ingénieurs des arbres faire tout
pour la victoire
[Applaudissements]
nous allons renforcer des garanties pour
les collectifs
de travailleurs se seront les salaires
et les conditions il faut qu'ils aient
la possibilité pour les industries de
l'armement de trouver des logements un
des plans athées pris qui vont être
subventionnés par le gouvernement pour
une partie importante
nous avons discuté de cela avec le
gouvernement il faut que tout ce
programme soit
développé dans ces moindres détails de
façon à ce que ces logements
subventionnés
soit développé dans nos villes de centre
de l'industrie de l'armement et de
d'institudes développement des armes ce
n'est pas une action
militaire
d'informations qui est
lancé contre nous par l'Occident et
c'est sur le front économique qu'ils
sont cherchés à nous attaquer mais ils
n'ont rien réussi à obtenir
je dirais même plus les
initiateurs de ces sanctions se
punissent eux-mêmes se l'entraîne
l'inflation dans ces pays-là
fermeture d'entreprises une crise
énergétique et à l'heure peuple ils
disent c'est la faute des Russes
quels moyens ont été utilisés dans cette
agression on a essayé de
couper les liens avec les entreprises
russes couper les
liens d'informations
empêcher empêcher nos entreprises de
leur
client et aussi il y a eu ce qu'il faut
appeler un vol de nos réserves en vie
mais tout cela ce ne sont que des moyens
alors que leur objectif est c'est les
chefs
il s'agit de faire souffrir nos citoyens
faire souffrir nos citoyens voilà ces
humanistes ils veulent t'obliger notre
peuple à souffrir et déstabiliser notre
société de l'intérieur mais leur calcul
s'est trouvé
erroné en fait la résilience de notre
économie et beaucoup plus forte qu'il ne
le supposait grâce au travail du
gouvernement du Parlement de la banque
de Russie et de la communauté des
entreprises et des travailleurs nous
avons assuré la stabilité notre économie
nous avons défendu les emplois nous
n'avons pas
laisser s'installer la disait dans les
produits de première nécessité en mars
de l'année dernière une somme de mesure
ont été lancées pour soutenir l'économie
et les entreprises c'est un trillion de
route qui a été mis en jeu Jacquier
votre attention ce ne sont pas des
politiques de planche à billets cela se
fait sur une base
solide
de l'économie de marché et en 2022 nous
avons eu une baisse du PIB
je voudrais que vous en parliez c'est
une information qui a été
diffusée et tout cela et
correspond au projet on nous avait dit
que notre
économie s'effondre réel de 25%, or en
2022 nous avons une baisse de notre PIB
de 2,1% en tout et pour tout en février
mars de l'année dernière on nous disait
que notre économie allait s'effondrer or
les entreprises russes ont modifié leur
logistique se sont orientés vers des
partenaires sur et fiables et dans le
monde ils sont la majorité par rapport
décembre 2021 nous avons enterrésève qui
ont augmenté
avec
deux vis de nos pays salissent plus de
moitié de l'eau
réserve 12 qui s'est nous allons créer
un système dérèglement internationaux
qui vont être
indépendant du dollar et des autres
devises de réserve qui font
de plus en plus avoir tendance à perdre
leur caractère universel et c'est leur
propre faute ça n'est pas nous qui
réduisons nos règlements en dollars
sont eux-mêmes qui le font vous savez
qu'il y a cette
expression des canons contre le beurre
bien sûr la défense d'un pays c'est ce
qui est la priorité première nous devons
pas répéter les erreurs du passé nous
devons pas détruire notre propre
économie nous avons tout pour assurer la
défense et pour créer les conditions
d'un développement sûr de notre pays
c'est dans cette logique que nous
agissons et que nous allons continuer
d'agir
[Applaudissements]
les plus essentielles non seulement
n'ont pas été réduites mais ont augmenté
par exemple la création de nouveaux
logements
plus de 100 millions de mètres carrés et
nous avons une croissance à deux
chiffres de notre production agricole
je rends au Binche à nos travailleurs
c'est un
récolte record 150 millions de tonnes de
céréales dans plus de 100 millions de
tonnes de blé donc en juin 2023 nous
pourront porter notre exportation à 55
voire 60 millions de tonnes il y a-t-il
sous 15 ans c'était
impensable c'était
un objectif qui
semblait tout à fait irréalisable
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
dans un passé tout récent encore je vois
le fils Premier ministre qui était
ancien ministre de l'or
de l'agriculture volant nous allons
exporter 55 à 60 millions de tonnes et
nous avons la possibilité de faire des
percées similaires dans d'autres
domaines nous n'avons pas perdu d'emploi
nous avons eu une baisse du chômage dans
des conditions qui sont très complexes
le marché de l'emploi
est en meilleure posture que
précédemment vous vous en souvenez avant
la pandémie nous avions 4,7% de chômage
et là nous avons 3,7% seulement
c'est bien 3,7% n'est-ce pas c'est un
minimum historique je le dirai
l'économie de la Russie a surmonté les
risques qui étaient survenus bien sûr
c'est risque ne pouvait pas être calculé
à l'avance il a fallu réagir
sur le coup
les décisions ont été prises d'une
manière extrêmement
spontanée rapide initiative
privée à jouer un rôle très important
les petites et moyennes entreprises nous
avons
évité le
glissement vers une économie
plus
avons constaté une croissance de
l'économie dès le troisième trimestre
nous avons une un nouveau cycle de
croissance
la structure ce modèle de croissance est
nouveau
ce sont les marchés mondiaux
qui
sont moteurs de même le marché intérieur
et aussi la production de produits à
haute valeur ajoutée cela permet de
développer le potentiel de récit dans
toutes les
domaines on voit une forte croissance de
la demande intérieure je pense que nos
entreprises utiliseront cette
possibilité pour développer la
production la plus demandée et
développer justement cette pollution
dans des niches qui ont été libérés par
les entreprises occidentales au début de
l'année et là on commence à voir se
dessiner l'ensemble du tableau on voit
les problèmes structurels de logistique
de technologie de finances et de
personnel de semaine nous savions qu'il
y a des besoins de transformation
fondamentale dans notre économie c'est
une nécessité vitale maintenant et cela
change la situation et c'est une
évolution positive nous le voyons nous
savons ce qu'il faut faire pour assurer
un développement sûr pour assurer un
développement indépendant indépendant de
toute menace où
influence extérieure avec une garantie
de la défense des intérêts de notre état
en fait notre travail a pour objectif
non seulement de s'adapter aux
situations actuelles mais il faut amener
notre économie à un nouveau régime de
fonctionnement tout change très
rapidement ça n'est pas un temps de défi
mais ce sont de nouvelles possibilités
qui s'ouvrent devant nous et c'est
vraiment le cas aujourd'hui et c'est
d'en tirer le meilleur profit de cela
dépend notre vie à venir il faut
éliminer les formalités les non-dits et
tous les tout ce qui entrainent la bonne
collaboration entre toutes les entités
toutes les
infrastructures il faut bien lancer les
entreprises en particulier les
entreprises de petites et des
entreprises familiales des kilomètres de
nouvelles routes ce sont des victoires
de nouvelles
écoles et jardins d'enfants construits
ce sont des victoires qui sont
des éléments à mettre au Pokemon de la
victoire commune
le partenariat entre l'État et les
régions
pour le développement de l'économie
locale nous allons créer de nouveaux
corridors logistiques une décision a été
déjà prise pour
[Musique]
et cela nous permettra de développer nos
objectifs de
croissance de la Sibérie et de
l'Extrême-Orient la croissance de nos
infrastructures la télécommunication et
en fin de 4 en 2024 dans les grandes
agglomérations et plus de la moitié des
routes vont être remises en étant
[Applaudissements]
du gaz gratuit et la gazification de
sera développé et cela d'une manière
constante les citoyens vont pouvoir
toujours
faire des demandes de raccordement au
gaz
partir de cette année nous lançons un
grand programme de restauration des
programmes du logement et il y aura 4,5
millions d'euros qui seront consacrés
dans les années qui viennent vous savez
à quel point cela est important parce
que c'est un domaine qui a été laissé à
l'abandon il faut que ce programme
puisse être lancé très rapidement il
faut que il soit financé de manière
stable il faut développer également les
possibilités technologiques de
l'économie russe et il faut
développer aussi
les hypothèques industriels et il faut
que l'on puisse
développer ses crédits aux entreprises
non seulement existantes mais pour la
création de nouvelles entreprises et ce
sera une somme
qui pourra atteindre jusqu'à 500
millions d'euros
ça sera trois à 5% sur un temps de
remboursement de 7 ans c'est un
programme qui sera intéressant et il
faudra le mettre en jeu à partir de
cette année il y aura ces nouveaux
clusters industriels
ou les entreprises résidentes vont avoir
une facilitation
administrative et ils auront la
possibilité de
bénéficier de
comment d'État à long terme et des
subventions en 2030 nous aurons donc
pour plus de 10 trillions de roubles la
réalisation de projets
qui sont particulièrement demandés et
dans ces premières années ce sera deux
trillions ce ne sont pas des pronostics
mais ce sont des
projets qui sont déjà clairement
en instant des mesures de soutien y
compris fiscales doivent être
entreprises bien sûr je sais que le
mystère des finances ne
n'est pas
en faveur de mesure
d'assistance fiscale mais cela ils sont
conscients que ces particulièrement
nécessaire à partir de 2023 aussi
les entreprises russes pourront réduire
leur
impôts sur les bénéfices s'il
promet des
projets
d'intelligence artificielle et de
et pour chaque rouble investi dans
l'achat de ce type de production de
nouvelles production en haute
technologie et de l'intelligence
et bien pour l'achat de matériel à haute
technologie de Russie et bien pour
chaque rouble dépensé il y aura un
roublé et demi apporté par l'étain
troisième point une question très
importante oui
c'est une bonne décision qui permettra
de
d'activer l'économie pour assurer la
croissance c'est les nouvelles sources
de
d'investissement grâce à une balance
des paiements excédentaires nous n'avons
pas besoin de
et de quémander une aide par des
investissements étrangers nos banques
nationales
fonctionnent de manière fiable et solide
en 2022 le volume des encours de
critiques ont augmenté
on avait des craintes à ce sujet
mais cette croissance a été notée
de 14%, c'est plus
qu'en 2021
en l'absence de l'opération militaire
cette croix sens avait été de 11,7% en
on se retrouve dans quelques quelques
instants pour pour la suite à